[Musique]
16,4 pour cent des emplois en france
risquent de disparaître à cause des
robots c'est une prévision de l' ocde
mais ce grand remplacement robotique
étaient déjà annoncés dans les années 60
c'est à cette période que
l'informatisation et la robotisation se
développe dans le monde du travail à
l'usiné mais aussi dans les bureaux et
au départ ses ouvriers dassier était
plutôt bien vu il ne s'agit donc pas
d'une suppression du travail humain mais
d'une promotion de celui ci pas encore
de réelles craintes de chômage causé par
ces machines mais l'espoir d'une société
constituée d'ingénieurs
le développement de l'automatisation
conduira au contraire a créé les
activités nouvelles
elle imposera l'apprentissage de métiers
nouveaux elle exigera un niveau
intellectuel plus élevé et les jeunes
programmateur encore étudiants se
vantait de ce nouveau métier payer trois
fois plus que celui d'instituteurs
musique le grand argument est lâché on
peut nous payer cher puisque la machine
dont nous sommes spécialistes remplace
du personnel l'ordinateur devient alors
le messager d'un grand fléau le chômage
fin des années 60 le spectre du chômage
fait donc son apparition les enfants
imaginent est d'ailleurs un monde où les
travailleurs étaient intégralement
remplacées par des robots les gens ils
n'auraient plus rien à faire parce qu il
ne travaillerait plus une fois qu'ils
auraient des robots y aurait des robots
pour fabriquer des robots les robots
furet la guerre et les gens grossirait
il ne ferait plus rien ils seraient ils
auraient suis pas dit il grossirait je
crois que la rage de l'homme se perd 20
début des années 70 les français sont
les témoins du remplacement des humains
par des robots et notamment les
parisiens dans le métro 6 et
d'automation intégral entraîne un
changement d'habitude pour les usagers
elle signifie avant tout la disparition
de 2500 points sonne alors vous allez
faire comment vous par exemple puisque
c'est votre cas qu'est ce qui va se
passer mais je vais être au chômage
alors robot créateur de chômage une
question complexe car selon l' ocde
s'il ya une automatisation des métiers
dans le secteur de l'industrie
ces robots entraîne aussi des créations
de postes dans le secteur des services
d'ailleurs au sein de l' ocde quatre
emplois sur dix créer cette dernière
décennie l'ont été dans des secteurs où
l' usage du digital est élevé
[Musique]